hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play it works must die too
I'm here with Tom hi hi Arizona okay and
we're gonna keep on rolling so on to the
precipice let's do this
let us i have specialized in tar who's
totally pro strategy I've specialized in
nothing good for you congratulations
physics is fun we must go through the
ribs how this is interesting fortresses
is it look at those things I'm not
looking I'm looking at least wait a
minute this isn't some evil person
suddenly turned a sexy partner trick
you're growing powers are a match for
mine are you afraid I know yeah look
what are you wait that came out wrong
huh ok so we'll be oh those things up in
the sky yeah I don't know what those are
oh those are we're flying figs spawn
yeah ok we're gonna need sealing stuff I
guess those new sealing trap we got ok
so where can I start bottlenecking them
I've got a super cheap guitar like dupa
cheap
I also finally put on a trinket which
heals me I guess I could use that in
combination with vampire
vampirism for the vampire gauntlets you
have those I do not have vampire goblins
but I have linked trinket here all right
so I suppose I could do it that way if I
really wanted to be more mana
specialization katar
but anyway where am I putting guitar uh
wherever I'll just put my chaps around
your tars all right I guess I'll a
bottleneck I'm here so they control the
air at the same time right do you have
anything for walls you know I don't at
the moment okay
see
all right and my my traps are my things
are actually super slow I got this
inflation ready whenever you are
I'm not ready now ready not ready
hang on okay
[Music]
so the carts are gonna come rolling
through here I should actually just a
good replacement for the carts is that
you clock a bunch of them yeah but I'm
worried about the other side once that
starts coming down oh I see what you did
my traps are all back there oh you want
me to put him back no it's fine I'm just
gonna eventually block off this okay
though it's gonna be a while you could
yeah we could block it down to one
pathway yeah and just keep this fun um
all right here okay then I'll move nah
no we'll just that'll be our second
stage right here okay this will be where
we'll hold them at first okay all right
that works for me all right unleash
davon time
oh you can get down right here
slide
I don't have let you go God when I
respect my skills
liars down
I keep killing your charms yeah sorry
I think I might just go back to the
blunderbuss because in these hours right
here
slows it was
yes but are they coming they're coming
from the other side now oh there's
another side yeah oh shoot I mean it's
up
yep they're they're ayahs in the air
this thing is not very accurate
I got Italy's get those on headshots
oh I can't get them very well
ah
out of debt or
and do you more
I try to hit the ones in the back so you
don't hit him yeah it just happens Wow
you
long round yeah
how much manages that charm cause a
pretty good deal
I can turn like three at a time and then
I run out of mana so you can see it when
I cast it oh yeah
can you charm like ogres and stuff yeah
that's where it most comes in handy
yeah I upgraded the wind belt too so
it's pretty fun ah alright so next I
guess they're probably gonna come out of
both sides next time yeah I think so
I'll block up the other one do you want
me to move my traps back no it's fine
where they are okay
stabbing time right first this will slow
them up
come and get some working
they walk right into this food rail
carts
yeah actually now that I think about it
oh yeah that would be smart
there we go perfect oh crap I'm almost
dead oh crap they're coming from this
side what Oh
except I can blow the that's it fall off
yeah yeah
okay that's us getting clobbered by that
yeah don't know why we didn't think of
this early carts have been linking every
onion every level wonder why we don't
want you kidding oh I got I'm still
almost dead
oh yeah there's no
oh yeah I got a trinket come here me
dude it ah there we go okay thanks
good kill now I got an ogre on my side
okay good
at this side get back another odor
coming up here kind of head shot
oh yeah forgot about those
cleaner ultra staff all right not bad
you want me to reposition these traps so
that you can funnel them through that
the the cart area could you do the same
over here I suppose
although my barricades over there got
destroyed Shannon wine I don't know huh
[Music]
I'm gonna fix these barricades back here
okay
maybe maybe because when the car came it
seemed to them like they had no path so
maybe for like stagger them I suppose
either way I got tons of money so
there we go all right
we're gonna have a tough time getting
down this ramp
this won't hurt a bit of course it won't
hurt tar doesn't hurt at all
is this my tar when this get here huh I
don't have tar whoops I made a move I
done goofed
yeah ready man look at all those tar
traps that's crazy
they only cost three hundred apiece for
me yeah but uh there's no traps here so
what are they gonna do slow down here
why don't you sell this rope tar right
here this is this right here and then
I'll just put flame traps there works
for me since you love your flame trap so
much I do
I've got spike traps Hey those are
useless you owe me a special accent
spike traps uh I don't think spike traps
are all that effective they can slow
they can yeah but they do almost no
damage you shut your face and they're
like whoa one-time use then after he
said shut up there's a trinket that
makes trap reset faster almost easy I'm
gonna add that circuit know what guitar
didn't need to [ __ ] I'm fine I'm going
I'm selling that barricade of useless
that's fine I could just you know I'll
never see it coming
slow
right work more MORE
hey I got him winning strategy press G
all right fine
liars BAM
wait I can charm oh I can I can charm
expire oh okay
Oh to ogres I got this side I got this
side
Wow
I know girl just exploded hey over show
me your head please thank you pliers
come on okay we're good how's your
someone getting through one getting
through what what give their flyer flyer
flyer flyer flyer
we're good prizes over
damnit I just place some
you need a he'll let me know I'm good
another overcome in my life
your way I got a picnic Oh
one down there two down we're good
and that's all she wrote
away 101 there we go bing-bong sillies
all right
not so bad eh yeah it's easy set those
Flyers occasionally again now that the
sticky situation
even more even more fun
oh-oh-oh gurgle fault
any fliers nope not so far she's done
that easy
well so far shut up
oh I swear
I swear I'm going back to the
blunderbuss after this really I'm a
specialize in spikes will imagine the
bloody spikes oh god don't have any
you're gonna see gonna see man oh yeah
it's gonna be awesome
you don't even know
Oh load
look I can pick one up soon pick one
what I can pick people up with the wind
belt oh oh
good it is but I can
how it's done at all oh man I got so
much stuff so many stick a good use
oh never mind deal a sticky your end no
I wanted you to sell one of these uh-huh
but celadon I can't sell it I can't
thought I could
they're coming out of my side daya
fliers coming on wolves
I got an over
oh crap I got two ogres I got to agree
Flyers on my side are done
like a flock before
come on ah dunk dunk douche one ogre
down I got to go
oh I got headshot dude [ __ ] I might be
in trouble
you're in trouble I got a Gollum
breathing down my neck oh crap there we
go okay we're gonna get know you
none of us you mother [ __ ] yeah you like
suddenly pick up super speed like that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
get back
get back [ __ ] another golem I swear I
could headshot ways
I got this side good it's good to know
how you doing I'm so that just happened
and I really do need more traps okay
could you just sell these right here
these two just this one and this one
yeah just so they can go into my
grinders okie dokie
technically I've got launchers but yeah
yeah
I've got so much money and no no not
enough stuff to spend it on oh that's
such a [ __ ] thing you'll ever see I'll
just load up everything with hmm these
haymakers don't really do much haymakers
yeah the ones on the ceilings Oh Amy
yeah the ones we just got the the ones
that Nakamura
yeah those yeah I didn't even bother
with those I'm good you're good okay I'm
good dibs on New York's liars go down
easy [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] you golem elemental it was an
upgrade that made cartoon
yeah that would be nice fun too
turn it lost count again well I got
flowers in my in my skies crowd
what nothing going on just the pliers
you need help I'm fine I just didn't see
him
I swear I'm hitting this guy right in
the face not real three there we go ah
get a brightness face
oh heck oh boy I got two golems and
wires I might be in trouble
hi chandram thank you
I forgot I haven't I have a stunt
Canadian Emma oh yeah you should send
them and turn the minecart yeah I don't
know I'm just
haha it's always funny to see just a
bunch of mom go flying it is it is nice
I like it a lot it's my favorite one
hey what's wrong with your side my sides
all done
shut up five no chilly traps to do
everything manually come on I'm gonna go
spy craft specialization just you wait
if you say so wait oh it's gonna be it's
gonna it's gonna be bang man sure it's
two more rounds to go actually I'm gonna
put some traps on the ceiling to stop
the Flyers maybe this will make the
haymakers more useful oh it's gonna be
back that's a sticky situation
BAM
I really do need something else yeah
not cut it wow that's a lot of jet
oh I can knock about drama sighs you
might make yeah it's really useful on a
level like this fires come on what's
this you're a flare behind
let's it get there oh you got flyers I
got him I got it Mike no worries I got
it thank you
now brown fish kill Street rack left for
mass or killing
like a pom bar they can't block
I've just already resolved to make an
episode for a level
like up 40 minutes yeah the later ones
will probably get pretty long I'm okay
with that
hey giving people more things
yep yeah hey Mork sanyasa for a I'm
gonna lay down spike truck just cuz I
can that's the only thing I have Dennis
final live really time hi hi you douche
big stop hey
look out flyers
oh crap
I turned around and there was ogres
right behind me
oh come on hit them in their heads
I gotta go over the Flyers
and John egg shot
kind of head shot glance off their big
fat skull shot
you look like you're in trouble I'm not
shut up I kinda looks that way no no I
got it
[ __ ] wait laughs close Oh awesome
I know right I did upgrade my wind so
that it could push
oh this is overs my weapon my main
weapon isn't like you
yeah I suppose
all right it's like you always got to
aim just up Oh
right
getting bored over there got to come
over to my side I figured I might help
out
like that spike trap wonders
oh yeah here we go halfway there
all right I didn't take you long
Oh what are what happened what a mess
nothing uh-oh we didn't get the part I'm
it took us 22 minutes and it was
supposed to take 1830 yeah my bike no
yeah it does Michael all right anyway oh
that's all the time we got for this
episode thank you all so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye bye bye